Je vous présente mon chat.
Elle s’appelle Nitro. C’est une femelle.
Vous avez de la chance parce qu’habituellement
elle n’aime pas beaucoup les caméras.
Elle doit avoir envie de faire une petite sieste.
Un chat dort en moyenne 12 à 16 heures par jour.
Principalement pendant la journée.
Comme beaucoup de chats qui vivent en liberté,
Nitro passe une grande partie de la nuit dehors…
Même en plein confinement.
Elle peut parcourir des kilomètres dans l’obscurité,
ça ne la dérange pas.
Comme ses congénères, elle est nyctalope.
Ses yeux sont conçus pour voir dans la nuit.
Je vais vous montrer.
D ‘abord la pupille possède
un très grand rayon d’ouverture : fermé, ouvert.
Pour capter un maximum de lumière y compris la nuit
pour récupérer le moindre petit rayon de lumière.
Chez l’homme, la lumière est captée par des récepteurs situés sur la rétine : des cônes et des bâtonnets.
Ils transforment la lumière en signaux électriques
qui sont envoyés au cerveau via le nerf optique.
Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip…
Chez le chat, c’est exactement la même chose.
Mais le fond de l’œil du chat est en plus tapissé
d’une couche réfléchissante, le « tapetum »,
qui renvoie vers les récepteurs la lumière
qui est passée à côté.
Voilà pourquoi les chats voient mieux que nous la nuit.
C’est ce qui explique également
pourquoi on voit très bien les yeux du chat
quand il passe dans les phares d’une voiture.
J’adore les yeux de Nitro.
Un peu de vert en ce moment ça fait beaucoup de bien.
Comme une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Si vous avez aimé cette « capsule de déconfiné », n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise une nouvelle par jour.
Le mieux pour ne pas en louper,
c’est de vous abonner et d’activer la petite cloche.
A très bientôt et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.